It is easy to sit back and let others control
and influence our lives.
To give up and accept life’s conditions
as they are handed to us, without questioning
or selecting them.
But as humans, we have the profound ability
to choose.
The ability to examine, consider, and select
or deselect how we wish to live and see things.
If you sit submissive and choose to not choose
in life, you give others the ability to choose
for you.
You lose control of your unique psychological
world.
There are as many psychological worlds as
there are people within this one physical
world.
A psychological world is the objective world,
as a particular consciousness perceives and
experiences it.
It is the sum of a person’s genetic dispositions,
conditioned behaviors, and experiences, developing
into one unique vantage point.
As a result, 7 billion people experience a
slightly different color of the same world.
And every person experiences a slightly different
color of you.
People see you in the ways that fit their
own world.
And you do the same for them.
This is ok, though, because one can maintain
their own world while also existing in others.
What we must careful of, though, is losing
control of our own world in the process.
It is ok to inspire or be inspired by those
we encounter in life, but it is damaging to
completely accept all the versions of the
world that other people see.
When we do this, we accept everyone’s color
as our own and become a mix of TOO many colors,
all blending into a murky neutral brown.
Instead, we must be selective and conscious
of the colors we let our own mix with.
We must maintain a unique and beautiful color
that is distinctive and self-righteous.
The best way to accomplish this is by realizing
that your version of the world is not all
there is.
If your color is unique, than so must everyone
else’s.
When we realize this, we no longer feel the
need for our color to match with everyone
else’s.
We cease trying to absorb other peoples’
and other people’s will no longer be able
to passively absorb ours.
Only when we admit that the world exists in
seven billion different forms, can we begin
to focus on controlling our own.